in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jeff
and Kaylie are with us hey guys how are
you
we're doing great thanks so much for
having us well we're honored to have you
where do you live well we just moved
from Fergus Falls Minnesota back to
Moorhead Minnesota which is just right
across the river from Fargo North Dakota
ah there we go
very cool long way to Nashville it's a
long drive
well we're honored to have you here to
do your debt-free scream we are how much
have you paid off we put off thirty nine
thousand dollars and sixteen months way
to go
making what kind of money the whole time
approximately 74,000 very good very cool
I love it congratulations so what kind
of debt was this student loans and our
car okay and how long have you all been
married almost three years coming up on
three years now
on the 27th this month oh very good okay
so somewhere around 18 months into
marriage you looked up and said we make
seventy four thousand dollars we have
thirty nine thousand dollars in debt
what happened tell me the story well
about three years ago right after we got
married a pastor Kirkup and triumph
Lutheran Brethren Church in Moorhead
asked us to actually lead the class
because he was desperate for a leader
and Keely and I hadn't gone through the
class yet and it was our first year of
marriage and we said no for two reasons
one we hadn't taken the class hit and
two we just really wanted to focus on
our marriage for that first year mm-hmm
and about a year and a half ago I was
driving to a football meeting and on my
way there right I was right outside a
Fergus my car broke down and so I called
my dad he helped me in when I came back
from the football meeting
I talked to kaeleen I said Kayla we
really need to get gizelle in tents with
our debt and so we had seven thousand
dollars in the bank we spent six
thousand a car took out a little loan
for the rest and then kept a thousand
dollars for a baby step one and now
we're here and then you tore in her show
did you end up going through the
classroom we did we first took that the
class um last fall actually and then we
decided to teach it in the spring this
just this last spring oh wow watch for
leading we appreciate it welcome that's
very fun well congratulations you did it
sixteen months you just so once you
decide to do something it's just like
boom yeah
it was it was tough going through it
especially when we heard the caller's
call in and say you know before you have
a baby do you need be debt-free and
Kaylee and I were talking about starting
a family soon and every single time you
know you're like you don't have to be
out of debt and so we look at each other
and say do we want to stop this move we
decide not to and we're actually
pregnant now all right what a great year
yeah so figure well that's fun
congratulations thank you very cool
so first babies on the way no debt in
the house life is good
yeah very good what do y'all do for a
living I'm a high school math teacher
and a football coach uh-huh and I'm an
optician and a nurse okay very cool well
congratulations you guys so what was the
hardest part for you guys I think the
hardest part for me initially was when
we created our budget knowing that I was
only gonna have 30 dollars every month
to spend for my free money and I was
kind of a sacrifice initially just
because I was like okay this is my $30
that I get every month on if I want to
buy a shirt or if I want to go for
dinner with girlfriends that was the
hardest thing for me initially I think
but and also just getting on the same
page with one another once we had that
together we were really were able to
work as a team and we were really
grateful for that so the budget fight
when you first get this started and
tough it was difficult right away I know
I'm being a numbers guy I like you to
say this is how much debt we have we
want to get it done in X amount of
months and so that's what we got to pay
out sounds like a math teacher yes right
and I think the hardest part for me was
having to change the budget every month
you know for the most part it was the
same but different months we had
different expenses I think was
frustrating is that you know we wanted
to pay right away we started paying
eighteen hundred dollars a month out
honors on our loans and off the car and
some months is only nine hundred and
some ones were three to four thousand
Wow I'm in the summertime I sell
concessions just at different county
fairs and so it was kind of nice being a
teacher to get two checks in in the
middle during the summer and so that
really that really helped us you can
jack it up during that time very cool
very cool I love it
congratulations so now you're leading a
class
and someone comes up to you and they say
I don't know I can do this I don't know
if I can if I can live on a plant I
don't know a budget feels so
constricting what do you tell them the
key to getting out of debt is I think
the key is just to be intentional every
day not just with your money but with
your life we talked about a Bible study
and I've talked about it with my class
with students you know you can wake up
every day and you can just go through
the motions or you can wake up with a
plan you can be intentional and I hear
you talk about all the time with the
show with other phone colors coming in
you know if you're intentional with just
with anything including money you will
succeed every single time mm-hmm yes I
want it eventually I mean it takes a
while and it's always a price to be paid
but Kelly what do you say the secrets
are definitely you have to want it we we
wanted this before we had our family and
and and we worked so hard to get here
and so we're so grateful yeah that's fun
well you did it you did it it's a great
feeling isn't it it's awesome and we do
get we actually just got the call from
Kelly on Tuesday she goes are you in
town because you said you'd be able to
come either Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
and I was standing in my yard and furgus
cleaning our house because we just sold
it and I was like well we'll be down
Thursday and so we made the check
yesterday all day and it was worth it oh
my gosh Wow well I'm glad you made it
congratulations thank you all right Jeff
and Kaylie Fargo North Dakota 39
thousand dollars paid off 16 months
making seventy four thousand dollars a
year oh and there's a baby on the way
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two what
love it love it love it
congratulations you two very very well
done
that is so fun man that's neat
congratulations I mean we've had a
lineup today of young couples and coming
in here under 30 years old doing this
stuff houses paid for their getting out
of debt completely on everything else I
mean it changes everything you think
about it what would be like to have no
payments no I Ament that I wasn't
kidding what would it be like to have no
payments let me breathe that in for a
second and you'll understand what the
Bible means in proverbs 22:7 the
borrower is slave to the lender I ever
met a generous slave hard to be generous
when you're slave you ever met a slave
who was excited about the future it's
hard start to feel like a victim you
start to feel trapped start to feel
bitter feel like a rat in a wheel just
run run run run getting nowhere - many
people live their lives that way so you
know I'll help you with every detail
I'll remind you all day long every day
all three hours the show with the baby
steps are why you're not the exception
I'll walk you through this but you got
to learn to get out of debt you gotta
learn to get on a plan you have to learn
to save for emergencies for purchases so
you have no more debt and for the future
for your retirement your kids college
you have to build and maintain quality
relationships you have to increase your
generosity those of you there
evangelical Christians your baseline
your minimum is a tithe it's a tenth of
your income going to your local church
that's our guideline for those of us
that are people of faith
and if you're not a person of faith you
know have that you don't follow you're
not a person of the book then you know
you just need to increase your
generosity because generosity changes
your life and I want you to be more than
ten person I want it to be outrageous
generosity as you go along but you've
got to hit certain goals and you've got
to be wise about how you're going to
unfold these things to live on less than
you make you think you are Congress see
people spin like you're in Congress well
they got a factory up there they print
money what are you going to do oh you're
screwed that's what you're going to do
until you stop that stupidity so you
stop the spending man it's out of
control
ridiculous what you spend in restaurants
alone is ridiculous yeah I'm talking to
you you
this is the Dave Ramsey show